on this episode we talk about stupid
questions integrity and relationships on
social media
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 109 of the askgaryvee
show India let's get into action before
we get into that it's been really fun to
get the wonderful feedback on social of
how many people have missed the show we
were on a real roll there for five or
six weeks so not having a show for an
entire week definitely built up to the
man for episode 109 so I'm as equally
fired up to deliver the Emmy finals have
been phenomenal
Stefan was super tough on me in
basketball today I heard my are you
what's this mean Steve that you're up to
I'm like trying to create a fake show
for Stefan is that what you're on
where's it is a real show no yes that's
the EP that he's getting why don't you
show Steve while he's talking
Stefan hasn't Holland coming up cool
Steve has a reddit competitor website
coming out in three months as well let's
get into the show we have to talk about
that at some point right I mean with the
fan base that's a lot of black and white
for you there d-roc all right
Eduardo asks I don't understand why I
barely see Gary Vee and my Twitter feed
but all over my Facebook account
I'd want a great great statement a great
question and the answer is because of
the attention graph see what I don't
think people understand is Twitter's
firehose and this is notwithstanding
Chris sokka's amazing rant that I
haven't read but so I can't even say
it's amazing but the amazing feedback to
his amazing rant and he's one of the
great investors of this generation a
good friend of mine I'm dying to read it
Chris I promise I will read it probably
late August when I'm with my family um
you know while they're sleeping and I'm
being a good dad but I have a chance to
read
I think Twitter's firehose is just noisy
and I'm tweeting away and I think I even
double check that one to see if you were
following me and you are it's just busy
and there's a ton of [ __ ] going through
your stream and you're just not seeing
it and now that I changed my profile
picture and you don't see the pink in
the corner
you're really missing it so you know
Facebook just has more attention as does
Instagram which is the best at this game
snapchat at some level especially cuz
you're holding it but like using stream
terminology the screams Instagram one
Facebook to Twitter three a lot will
jump in and leave comments on this
episode of know for me it's Twitter and
I get that people that have done a
better job keeping a small group of
following down but as an overall big
data play Facebook is winning that game
it's more obvious I just think you know
even like the ui/ux Facebook posts are
bigger I just think that um I think
Twitter's noisy and I think the reason I
picked this question because I did
forward this one to you India is because
the question is the point that I'm
trying to make which is you're noticing
it more because you're noticing it more
think about that
Christopher asks you get questions all
the time some you like some you hate do
you feel that there is such a thing as a
stupid question of course I think you
know I'm not gonna go cliche here I
think there's probably an enormous
amount of stupid questions you know
there's a lot of stupid people with
stupid points of view but nobody gets to
be the judge and the jury of that stupid
what may be stupid to me is not stupid
to Stefan and vice-versa and so thus I
think the judge and the jury the person
that makes the decision whether it's
stupid is making that decision and so
you know I mean I think I think 99% of
the questions people ask me are stupid
at some level truthfully especially when
they're the things that come most
natural to me because people aren't
asking me questions of biophysics or the
weather or traffic the theory or just
the I mean like I look at traffic not
web traffic you know like people don't
ask me a lot of questions about things
that I'm not knowledgeable in and so I
think all of us when we have a depth of
knowledge of something can think things
are stupid because we know them well and
others don't
stupids an ugly word by the way I hate
that goddamn word but the energy of the
question is the there's a human that
besides if it's stupid or not
I think the politically correct answer
to this question is no you learn from it
well in all that and I'm into being PC I
think you know I'm sure some of the
homies here thought I would go that
route with this answer but not India but
d-roc maybe he gets tricked sometimes
and so and so that's that guys yes there
are stupid questions
this question is amazing go ahead Ryan
asks my bro has been dating a girl for
two years and she still refuses to
acknowledge their relationship on social
media red flag Ryan your brother isn't
deep any relationship that is two years
old where one of the people in the
relationship has not acknowledged it
publicly on a social network platform is
up to some scandalous period end of
story
there's nothing else to be said there I
don't want to hear that you like to keep
it private on the DL like scandalous
tommy lasorda
let's do it this is Tommy Lasorda Gary I
want to ask you how do you keep your
people motivated Tommy thanks for the
great question
you know obviously being one of the
great managers of all time this answer
is gonna come very easy to you and very
natural I think you'll get it I think I
spent a lot of time thinking about
motivation and I think the key for me is
I try to motivate in a couple ways
number one by example I think my actions
will always speak louder than my words
so how I carry myself how I interact
with everybody how I live myself like I
live my life as a man I think really
matters as a and as an executive as a
person I think everyone's always
watching but I also think I equally try
to reverse-engineer every single
individual person right they're just all
different they all have different KPIs
different objectives they're in
different parts of their lives
some are married some just had kids some
are trying to make more money some don't
want to have four roommates in Brooklyn
like so they're grinding so like
everybody's got a different thing and I
think what's important for me
to motivate is to do a great job
listening to what makes them tick both
when I have the few moments with them in
person like Alex
get over here for a second so like he
looked a real-life example on the
askgaryvee show Alex what what motivates
you what are you what are you excited
about like what yeah like what motivates
you in life I just like doing cool
alright like that's it like pretty much
I want to like be successful and just do
cold it's basically why I'm here
so you know cool man all right get out
of here so you know Alex is easy he just
wants to do cool so that's easy we do
tons of cool
please check he's good he's motivated
and you go on and on and you try to
figure out was that like he was scared
that he was on camera is that the real
answer like are they gonna really tell
me the truth
doing they never tell me the truth
usually upfront few and far between and
so it's a constant you know behavioral
HR driven reverse engineering what they
care about like Indy and I had a pretty
intense conversation about her future
ambitions
like what yeah remember you wanted to be
the head of social media for museums and
things like I took that very seriously
like I know these things about my peeps
is long before India was on the inner
circle of this team like like like I
remembered it better than you did
seriously let's so like I mean so I take
an enormous flick you don't get to be a
great all-time leader without being a
great all-time leader so there's a lot
of work that gets put into being good at
what I do and I'm very very up to the
challenge and so it's predicated on an
enormous amount of listening which is
why I'm such a paradox because boy do I
love to talk but the amount of listening
that I'm actually doing always surprises
people when they start going a couple of
layers deeper so the answer to your
question is I motivate Tommy by figuring
out what every single person is ticked
and wired like and what makes them roll
and I also recognize that that changes
every single day and they have four to
seven twelve milestone things that
happen in their lives which will change
the trajectory of their ambitions wants
hopes and dreams and I need to be
prepared for every single one of those
for all of them forever
Dylan asks did you still believe that
there's integrity in the communications
industry
Dylan I want you to and I think the
answer is there absolutely is but I
think that there's integrity there's
very little integrity and in very in
every single market the advertising
politics sports music like the you know
the reason integrity is so attractive is
it's so hard it's far and few between it
and integrity is defined differently by
everybody and I think it's interesting
to watch I actually think society is
giving people more room to be flawed
which is intriguing I think the level of
integrity what in the way integrity is
viewed upon today I think is in a much
better place than it was by society
let's say 50 years ago because I think
we're now factoring in that nobody's
perfect and we're making mistakes even
by standards like drugs and
relationships and cheating like like
like intense stuff I think there's an
interesting evolution and I and I think
that you know that's allowed for a
little bit more gray and a little bit
more if you're really on your high horse
creating a scenario where you judge
integrity but I think I think in a lot
of ways there's plenty of integrity I
think there's a ton of integrity out
there still I think I've been saying
this a lot lately it's I said in another
video are we gonna bang out that video
that I didn't just earlier today one no
I know the last one we did that's yeah
yeah I'm working on it
in there I say or me no I think it was a
different one it was in another one I
screwed up but the I'm a big fan of this
thing that sent on my mind right now
which is you find what you're looking
for you know I see integrity every day
every day and I think it's because I
look for it and I look half glass full
like this is Niagara Falls to me like
this is a very full glass and I think
that plenty of people can see can see
plenty of what's missing I think that's
as much on you my man as it is on what's
actually happening in the marketplace
yeah he's a good episode it felt good
about myself when deep 109 was a deep
episode she just showed DeMaio just for
kicks and giggles let's go through the
camera let's find him the man the camera
will find you don't try that
you know don't try to don't try to hide
what's up everybody
Tamara you get to ask the question of
the day oh boy what are you gonna get AJ
for his wedding yeah you're asking the
entire vaynernation
but you know what we're keeping that
what are you getting AJ for his wedding
this weekend you keep asking questions
we'll keep answering yeah I'm willing to
give me some briefly yeah give me like
an hour to get like yeah speak Faliszek
I want the kids said it like I don't
know like give me some breathing room
but I'll take like an hour in there you
know